lefty tarik skubal 1-7 5.23 era
basketball mid to upper 90s he does have
a big curve and a changeup that brings
up aaron judge
sharply to third on the backhand
candelario there's one castro's relay in
time
sweet dp
for the tigers here in the first
michelle is a right-handed matter deep
in the right hand of batter's box
upright open stands hands are tight by
the right shoulders he [ __ ] the bat
over it 2-2 swinging a soft line drive
to zach short at short
for the new york yankees it will be
michael king making his first start of
the season is his fifth career start
only going to go about 60 pitches
now here is jamer candelario
now he's at 286 four homers 18 rbis
another switch hitter batting left all
right here's the 3-1 coming to
candelario
and the pitch is popped up
foul off third o'shella has about a mile
and a half to run and he makes a catch a
backhand catch falling into the stands
and throws back to second base terrific
play
so first and second one out and here's
jonathan scope
now here comes the 02 to scope runner's
lead pitch is cut on the misses a
breaking ball that struck him out
swinging
nice pitch by king
and there's
now two way with runners at first and
second
i'll leave it up to nomar mazara
the 3-2 swing to line drive and fairball
down the left-field line into the corner
bounces off the stands frazier over to
get it miguel cabrera is rounding third
and he's headed home he ran through the
stop sign and he scores down to third
goes mazara
two out two run double and a two nothing
lead for the tigers i just love it when
miguel just runs through the stop sign
and he's laughing all the way that's
what's so funny about it the big fella
got going a little bit there chef he
couldn't stop he just said well
it's all or nothing right now sorry chip
i had the blinker on
and i couldn't get it off
eric haas
the young catcher the one two
is swung on and popped up foul and
caught by and duhar
in foul territory however the tigers
take the lead
they get two runs on two hits and leave
one
and duhar all for four yesterday in the
start and he was starting left field
scooble strikes him out on three pitches
two away wade just nine for 32 again
this is a very pitchable hitter at the
plate
[Music]
here comes the 3-2
and the pitch cutout i missed struck him
out swinging slider down and in
so bases loaded two out and here is
miguel cabrera pitch swung on and
grounded to third a shella goes to
second for the force and the yankees got
out of the jam john carlos stamp the o2
swinging to miss wow
he stepped in the bucket and flailed a
curveball in the dirt gets stanton he
strikes out for the fifth time in seven
plate appearances in this series your
judge the o2 swing and a miss he got him
with a slider down and in beautiful how
about that
eight pitches to get lemay hughes
stanton and judge and he dispatches
stanton with a curveball and judge with
a slider
fourth strikeout ends the third tigers
bad bottom of the third inning here's
victor reyes the strike one swinging the
ground ball softly deep at short enough
the glove of labor torres my goodness
into left field scoping the score over
the third goes house and down to second
goes victor reyes it has been a complete
meltdown for the yankees in all areas in
this weekend series against the tigers
tigers have a three-nothing lead castro
hit by a pitch his first time up the
strike one to castro swinging a ground
ball fair down the third base line haas
is in reyes is in zach short is being
waved around third and he will score
without a throw
three run double for willy castro six
nothing tigers in the third
maggie has been hit by a pitch and
grounded into a force
as we look at an 0-1-2 cabrera
and the pitch is grounded to third
ashela
throws to first
the the tigers bat around
well if you don't think players care
well watch clay betorus
he is furious at himself for making
those two errors just throwing his glove
down georgella leads off one two
swinging a miss
slider away and her shella weighing in
this is something it really is
that brings up miguel in duhar
the o2 is swinging a miss he got him
with a high riding fastball oh is he
tardy or what
and duhau strikes out sixth strikeout
for skubal ends the fourth walk does no
harm so far he's given up a bloop single
that's it
two away for glaiber
torres this one's popped up
right field for mazzara into shallow
right mazzara comes in puts that in his
back pocket for out number three
that's probably the end of the day for
tarek skubal that is a terrific six
inning starts part of pitching with
supreme shut the yankees out on just
three hits tigers bad at the bottom of
the sixth inning they've got a six
nothing lead over new york
well eric haas
is the hitter he is oh for three
he's got the bases loaded two out
here's the one two
cut on a miss struck him out swing on a
slider
and in the inning no runs one hit three
left
and now at the end of
six innings of play six nothing tigers
there's glebe torres
there's a base hit the first base hit
with runners in scoring position in the
series
one run scores moving to third
is judge and the yankees are on the
board at 6-1
tigers
sanchez against fulmer one run in two
odds eighth inning 6-1 tigers
and grabbed by the shortstop the long
throw to first it gets past scope
one run is scored
moving to third is torres
and they have
gary sanchez in a rundown oh my goodness
how do you do that
when you're down by four
wow
and now
they're most reliable and best hitter
[Music]
will come up with a chance to tie it
with one swing against former
two for six
in his career judge has 13 home runs
29 runs batted in
the one-two to judge
yes sir
got him looking
and the tigers
broom the yankees out of detroit